This woman has gone viral for being called
the ungrateful food bank lady.
No fresh fruit,
there's no veggies,
there's no toilet paper.
Everybody that does go to the food bank,
there is not one thing I'm gonna eat in here.
I guess I'm going up to the backyard
to go find my frozen dandelions,
and I'm gonna go, uh,
fry those up in some water.
People were mad because she criticized the food
she received from a food bank,
as she continues to show off the canned goods
in a sarcastic tone.
Sliced pineapple.
Okay, this is probably the only good thing. Again,
the cannon is dented or whatever.
This was her response after the backlash negatively
about me not being grateful for processed,
disgusting food. And, oh,
by the way, my nails.
Are you kidding me?
My oldest daughter got me a gift card,
so I like pretty things.
I like my kids to be healthy and eat healthy food.
And so do I.
Some pointed out that she must have had money
if she could afford a smartphone and get her nails done.
Some pasta. But we have anything to put on this pasta?
She faced a lot of backlash
and eventually deactivated her account.
But considering her dietary preference,
do you think she should have just donated the food?
Peanut butter
or what would I put my peanut butter on?